Most people think that writing a good
book is a game of good information and
luck, but that's wrong. What you
actually need is a simple step-by-step
system that gets readers to recommend
your book to others without needing
clever marketing or social media
campaigns. So, in this deep dive, I'm
going to show you exactly how to design
your book for wordof mouth
recommendability. And you're probably
thinking to yourself, will this actually
work for me? Well, over the past 10
years, I've worked with close to 2,000
non-fiction writers, and almost every
single one of them is making the same
mistake. They follow the writing advice
that we give in school. Like, be
nuanced, be objective, and readers hate
that. So, the next three points of
advice I'm going to give you are going
to be a software update, helping you
unlearn the writing rules from school
and learn to write from the reader
perspective. And just for a quick
example for how to design your book for
word of mouth recommendation, here's
something that happened to me last week.
So, I met a friend of mine for coffee
the other day and in the middle of our
conversation, she brings up a book
called Bad Therapy. Maybe she thinks I
need some therapy. It's a pretty
provocative title and the book itself
takes a pretty bold stance, which is
that therapy might actually be making
kids more anxious. So, that's great
because it's the kind of thing that
everyone has an opinion about and it's a
really polarizing topic. But, as we
started discussing the book, I came to
find out that she hadn't actually read
it. So, this got me thinking, why would
she recommend a book that she hadn't
even read? But the more I thought about
it, the more this actually made sense,
not logically, but socially. And from
the publishers's perspective, this is
gold. This is exactly how wordof mouth
recommendation works. A bold title, a
strong opinion. You don't even need to
crack the spine of the book open to feel
like you got the gist of it. And that's
kind of the point. My friend wasn't
really recommending the book. She was
signaling something about herself.
Recommending bad therapy was her way of
saying that, "Hey, I'm the kind of
person who questions the status quo. I'm
tuned in to edgy, thoughtprovoking
ideas. I think therapy is for
If you actually knew her, you would know
that she would never say something like
that. But that's the gist of it. The
point here is that the book became a
tool, not for reading, but for identity.
And this is exactly how ideas spread.
Think about social media. What gets
shared more, the nuanced balanced
content or the bold emotional takes? We
all know the answer. It's the hot takes,
not because they're more thoughtful, but
because they're more sharable. And this
is what so many non-fiction authors
don't understand. They think that they
need to be nuanced and objective because
that's what we taught them in school.
But if your goal is to have your book
read and shared, then you need to
understand that you are not in the
business of logic and nuance. You are in
the business of persuasion. And to do
that effectively, you need more than
just facts. You need ethos, pathos, and
logos. So what does that mean? Well,
ethos is your credibility. It's why
someone should trust you. Pathos is the
emotional impact, how your message
feels. And logos, that's the logic.
That's the actual argument that you're
making. So, if word of mouth
recommendability is what you want for
your book, then you need to stoke the
pathos and ethos by following the 3V
framework. Now for the first V of this
framework, the important thing to
understand is that readers who are
confused do not leave five-star reviews.
The secret if you want good reviews for
your book is to make the book's promise
so clear that anyone who is not the
right reader can tap out before they've
even bought it. Vague promises invite
the wrong crowd. And this crowd punishes
you for wasting their time. Now, if you
want proof, take a look at these two
books, which tackle the same problem,
which is creating offers that customers
actually want. The first one is called
Value Proposition Design. It was
published in 2014, and it has today
about 2,300 reviews. The second one,
Alex Hermoszy's 100 million offers. Now,
that was published a lot more recently
in 2021, and as of today, it has more
than 26,000 views. Same topic, different
promise. Hormosi spells it out on the
cover. How to make offers so good that
people feel stupid saying no. Now, as a
promise that is bold, concrete, and
irresistible. Compare that with the
promise of value proposition design. It
sounds smart, but it's a little bit
fuzzy. So few readers feel certain that
it's right for them and the ones who
misy this book are quick to complain.
Now to tell you the truth, I use this
same filter on this YouTube channel. I
usually open videos these days with
something like if you're a non-fiction
writer or I put non-fiction right there
in the title. That way writers who are
interested in writing fiction bounce.
And that's perfect because it's better
to lose the wrong viewers than to
collect a bunch of down votes and salty
comments. When you make a specific
promise, you do two things. You
magnetize the right people and you let
the wrong people excuse themsel. The
ones who stay with your book know
exactly what to expect. And when you
deliver on that promise, they're going
to leave you fivestar reviews and tell
all their friends. So, here's how you
can nail the promise of your book. The
most important thing is to name the
change. If you're writing a non-fiction
kind of prescriptive book, then you need
to be able to answer the question, what
will be different in my reader's life
after the last page? Of course, we want
our readers to learn something. But what
does learning mean? Okay, learning means
your behavior changed. A great example
of this is touching the stove. Okay. So
if you touch a stove, you burn your
hand, that pain is information. Now if
you take in that information and your
behavior doesn't change, that is if you
touch the hot stove again, you haven't
learned anything. But if you touch the
hot stove, you burn your hand, take in
the information, now your behavior
changes. Well, there you've learned
something. So, if you say you want your
readers to learn something from your
book, then you should be able to say,
"How is their behavior going to change
after reading it?" Once you've named
that change, I want you to say it out
loud. Pitch your book in one tight
sentence to a real person and then stop
talking. Just watch their face and
listen to the sounds that come out of
their face. This is really important
feedback. And when you get it, even when
they're confused, I want you to sit
through it. Okay? So, every time you get
a puzzled look on somebody else's face
when you explain to them the pitch of
your book, that's telling you what you
need to sharpen. So, you want to keep on
tweaking that promise until you can
deliver it to a new person in one or two
sentences very clearly. And fourth, when
strangers get it on the first try, it's
time to lock it in. Freeze that line.
That is the book's subtitle. You're
going to put that on the back of your
book and on the Amazon product page.
That's why the first part of the 3V
framework is called a vow. When you make
a clear promise, you attract the right
readers. And when you deliver on that
promise, you get rewarded with
recommendations and five-star reviews.
Now, for the second part of the 3V
system, I know you want to write a
bestseller, but what if the advice for
making it to the New York Times
bestseller list is exactly what's making
your book fail? I see this every week.
Early drafts are packed with tips for
beginners and experts, solopreneurs, and
Fortune 500 executives. One chapter on
mindset, the next on advanced analytics.
The impulse to pack in as much
information for as many different
readers makes sense. If your book helps
more kinds of people, surely it will
sell more copies, right? Well, not
quite. That logic works only if your
endgame is a mass market bestseller.
James Clear pulled it off with Atomic
Habits. And the sneaky thing about this
mega bestseller is that it's not really
a book about habits. It's actually a
book about elite performance and
deliberate practice. But by positioning
this book about habits, he aligned it
with a pain that almost everyone feels.
That is, I can't stick to good habits,
which is brilliant for book sales, but
it's not the right strategy if your book
is meant to attract clients, build your
authority, or solve a very specific
problem for a very specific reader. Let
me show you a better model. When I
launched this channel, Writer Science, I
made the classic mistake. I said, "I
help writers." It sounded smart, broad
appeal, right? But then came the inbox
chaos. I had a few videos take off and I
opened up a coaching offer. But I
started getting requests from all kinds
of different writers. fiction authors
asking about their story arcs and
fantasy writers asking about world
building and people trying to write
memoirs asking about how to find the
hidden meaning in their own personal
experience. Don't get me wrong, these
were all talented writers, but they were
just not the people who I could
genuinely serve. And that's when I sat
back and realized that this isn't a
channel for writers. Like writers
already know how to write. But after 10
years as an English professor where you
know I work with scientists and
engineers. So I help people who don't
know how to write translate their own
experience and research into specific
value for specific readers. So they
don't need my help. And honestly a lot
of those early consultations didn't even
really want my help. They were kind of
debating me. So who am I here for? I'm
here for experts. people who have
expertise and knowledge and need to
translate that into specific value for
specific readers. That's my jam. So, I
rewrote everything, the homepage, the
offer, the tone, the voice. And rather
than talking to writers, I began talking
to expert writers, people who want to
turn their knowledge and expertise into
a book that does the heavy lifting for
their business. And almost overnight,
things started to change. Yes, I lost
some subscribers at the beginning, but
when my messaging got sharper, my leads
got better, and my sales calls started
feeling more like conversations with
people who were already halfway sold.
And that's because the pain I described
was the exact pain that they feel. And
this is the real power of narrowing your
audience. When you name someone's pain
precisely, they stop scrolling and lean
in because you're not just another voice
with advice. You're someone who gets it.
And don't just take it from me. Here's
Alex Horoszi explaining how the pain is
the pitch. I think that if you can
accurately describe a prospect's pain in
their own language, in their own
experiences, you can persuade them to
buy whatever your product is based on
how well and how knowledgeable they
believe you to be as a function of how
specific you are about the pain they're
experiencing. And so if I if I'm talking
to a business owner that's doing $10
million a year and I'm like this is
what's going wrong in IT, right? And
this is what's going wrong in sales and
this is what's going wrong in your
marketing and this is what's going on in
they're like okay I get it. I get it.
You you know where I'm at. I'm like
right. Do you want my help? I don't have
to make a promise. If I can describe the
pain so acutely and they're like he
can't know that pain this well and not
be able to deliver. That's why the
second V in this system is known as the
victim. the specific person who's in
pain and looking for relief. Don't try
to write to everyone. Write for the
person who's stuck, whose hair is on
fire, who thinks, "I can't keep doing it
like this." And once you've got that
victim locked in your sites, what's the
next move? Well, for the last feat in
the system, it's important to understand
that the fastest way to get readers on
your side is to pick a fight. People
crave belonging. And one of the quickest
ways to create that feeling is by naming
a shared enemy. When you call out what
your reader is against, they trust you
to lead them toward what they want. It
shows not just what you know, but what
you stand for. Take for example
Harley-Davidson. In the 1980s, they were
losing pretty bad to Honda and Yamaha,
which were faster, quieter, and smoother
bikes. Harley couldn't win on
performance. So, they leaned into
identity. So, while these Japanese
brands pushed as sleek designs and
silent engines, Harley went with loud
pipes, leather jackets, and American
steel. They stopped selling motorcycles
and they started selling rebellion. We
see the same moves with other brands.
It's Yeti versus flimsy disposable gear,
Patagonia versus fast fashion. Here's
how I use this system on this YouTube
channel. As everyone knows, in recent
years, we've seen the advent of AI
writing tools. And now it seems like
everywhere you turn, we're just being
flooded with this polished sounding
fluff that completely ignores readers.
That's my villain. And that's the
villain of this channel. Now, by calling
out that kind of writing slop, I really
make this channel a beacon for writers
who actually care about their readers.
We also see this in the example that I
gave earlier of bad therapy. It does the
same thing. Taking a swing at the
therapy industry, pharmaceuticals, and
soft parenting. When you have that kind
of a fight against a villain, it makes
your message so much more magnetic. It
attracts the right people and repels the
wrong ones. Now, most experts default to
logic and nuance, but identity and trust
run on emotion. So when you have a clear
enemy, it clarifies what you stand for
and starts to tap into that pathos and
ethos at the same time. So here's how to
take your stand. Think about your
reader, that specific reader we
identified earlier, and think about what
that reader already hates but maybe
hasn't named. Maybe take a broken
system, some lazy trend, or a shiny new
shortcut that causes real harm. Two,
call it out plainly. Make that villain
visible. In the world of copyrightiting,
we call this throwing stones at their
enemies. So, by taking a stand, you're
also standing up on behalf of the
reader, and they're just going to cheer
you on. Now, three, be sure to show how
your book gives readers the tools that
they need to fight back and win. They're
going to be using your arguments in
conversation, the same way that my
friend did with that book, Bad Therapy.
When you give your reader an enemy, they
will carry your book like a badge of
honor. Now, this 3V system is all about
positioning your book so that it
attracts the right readers. But how do
you make sure that they actually enjoy
your book when they start reading it?
Well, to make sure that your ideas make
it off the page and into the mind of the
reader, watch this video next because
it's going to show you four writing
hacks based on reader psychology that
are some serious weapons for your
writer's toolkit. So, be sure to go
check it out.